the federal government is working to
give rural Americans a resource that
many of us take for granted high-speed
Internet just three percent of people in
urban areas lack access to broadband but
in rural areas 35 percent of people have
no access at all that accounts for about
22 million Americans the FCC yesterday
committed two billion dollars in
subsidies over the next decade to help
telecom companies bridge that gap Tony
de copal visited Dawsonville Georgia
about 40 miles outside Atlanta to see
the cost of this digital divide Tony
good morning good morning the internet
is not a luxury in fact last year a
federal court defined it as a basic
utility like running water or
electricity but for millions of rural
Americans high-speed Internet ends
before their county line at this
optometry office in northern Georgia dr.
Brian Burke takes pride in his sleek
21st century technology I wanted to be
the most moderate office that we could
be but he has to run it at a
twentieth-century pace would you say it
feels like the 90s here you're serious
it does people can remember back to when
you do your dial-up and you would wait
for the you know for it to spin around
until you actually got a connection we
face that as a daily part of doing
business
the FCC defines high-speed internet as
download speeds of 25 megabits a second
dr. Burke's internet is half that speed
or less why couldn't you just call your
internet service provider and say hey I
need faster internet we have tried that
it's not been successful so this is our
server Burke says he spent more than 25
thousand dollars on a server to avoid
transferring large files online this
server is a replacement for high speed
that is correct but slowdowns at the
front desk still prevent at least 20
patients a week from getting in for
treatment the Internet is a physical
thing yes this is it this is the in turn
Internet this is the place where
networks actually connect to
Andrew Blum the author of a book about
the guts of the internet took us to a
tightly guarded room in New York to see
one of the hubs that connects broadband
users here with high-speed networks
elsewhere bandwidth in this room is
cheaper and more abundant than almost
anywhere else on earth
the challenge is connecting it where we
are right now to the rest of the country
burrow homes and businesses are far from
these hubs and often far from each other
in areas where fiber optic cable can
cost up to $40,000 per mile slow speeds
can make downloading songs take up to 16
times longer a movie that takes fear
within eight minutes to download
elsewhere can sometimes take up to an
hour and a half we are working as hard
and as fast as we can to get as close to
the customers as we can Jarrod Berkshire
runs Gorge operations for windstream one
of rural America's largest internet
providers he brought us to a home where
one of his technicians was installing
broadband why can't you bring high-speed
Internet to everybody in the countryside
well it's a challenge of economics if
you will trying to get further out into
the rural network with the density being
more and more spread out population
being more and more spread out it's a
challenge no matter what provider you
are in the meantime working from home is
a challenge for folks like Tom haver
moles who logs on instead at a nearby
lunch spot made it a mile oh we hear
about it all the time it's one of our
most pressing issues congressman Doug
Collins is trying to encourage
competition to connect that last mile he
introduced a bill to offer tax
incentives for companies to improve
their connections many people are locked
into monopolistic situations in which it
just really doesn't get better but
telecom crews say they're working to
make things better line by line mile by
country mile your message to rural
customers is patience patience yeah
we're gonna get there
and President Trump says he'd like the
expansion of rural internet to be part
of his trillion dollar infrastructure
overhaul but no details yet on how that
would work what's amazing about this
story's it's a reminder that the
internet for all the magic is a physical
thing if you don't build the cables you
don't put them in the ground it doesn't
work everybody thinks wireless wireless
behalf don't you have to wire things
yeah you have to build one of the things
that I've heard is justification in
years past is that by the time you build
out that infrastructure the technology
will already be a generation ahead so
you always be playing catch-up
essentially that's not the case anymore
if every home had a fiber optic cable
going to it liked it as a water line
everybody would have fast feeds wave
reporting Tony thank you very much